Donald Trump is Going Bonkers because
the Supreme Court has said this is it
your tax returns are going to the house
committee that is investigating you the
Supreme Court has said that is it a
Newsweek reporting Donald Trump's tax
returns at the mercy of leakers and
indeed as I've told you before
if and when Trump's taxes get to that
house committee
a lot of different people on that
committee could leak the taxes
I believe the taxes will leak I'm not
advocating for a leak I'm not
encouraging criminality I'm merely
giving you my prediction my prediction
is that these documents are of such
interest
that they will leak once they are in the
hands of that house committee and indeed
Newsweek reports the Supreme Court
decision to allow Donald Trump's tax
returns to be handed over to a house
committee will not result in the former
president's Financial records becoming
public
unless there is a leak in a ruling
Tuesday Supreme Court Justices rejected
Trump's attempt to block a lower court
decision to Grant the
democratic-controlled Ways and Means
Committee access to the IRS records now
interestingly with the house Taking Over
Control in January there is a sort of
time as of the essence element to this
but Trump is Going Bonkers posting to
his platform truth social truth
essential quote why would anybody be
surprised that the Supreme Court has
ruled against me they always do
it is unprecedented to be handing over
tax returns and it creates terrible
precedent for future presidents has Joe
Biden paid taxes on all the money he
made illegally from Hunter and Beyond
the Supreme Court has lost its honor
Prestige and standing by the way a third
of the Supreme Court is people Trump
picked and has become nothing more than
a political body with our Capital C
country paying the price they refused to
even look at the election hoax of 2020
shame on them
I would expect
expect
that Trump's taxes will leak if the
house Ways and Means Committee gets them
particularly if it gets them with such
little time to investigate before
Republicans Take Over Control of the
house that's a prediction let me know
what you think leave a comment if you're
watching on YouTube and make sure you're
subscribed at youtube.com this is new
YouTube is revamping everything okay
youtube.com slash at symbol the David
Pacman show youtube.com at symbol the
David packman show good habits have to
be sustainable in order to become habits
it has to be something you'll actually
do and when it comes to nutrition some
people have hours to plan out every meal
their exact vitamin intake I'm not doing
any of that I don't have the time here's
what's sustainable for me I start my day
with just a single scoop of ag-1 from
athletic greens it gives me the entire
day's worth of the 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics I want
from whole food sources it's just simple
it's just one scoop of ag1 I get all the
nutrients I want I don't have to do any
math use my protractor my TI-83 or take
a bunch of different capsules and pills
it's not some kind of wacky supplement
making a bunch of crazy claims you know
I would not promote something like that
ag1 is just a simple product it does
what it says it does it gives you the
daily nutrients and vitamins you likely
want vitamin A C E magnesium zinc
potassium in one simple scoop you keep
your body nourished you'll also get a
free year supply of vitamin D which I
take in the winter plus five free travel
packs at athleticgreens.com Pacman the
link is down below